comment vous avez appris la nouvelle
déjà parce que
on a moi j'ai appris la nouvelle par mon
grand frère du coup et en fait c'est un
de des amis de la famille qu'il a appris
par
un passant quelqu'un qui connaît
qu'est-ce qui vous a dit il y a eu un on
nous a dit qu'il y avait un problème au
niveau du devant le lycée et que il y
avait un problème avec les jeunes donc
du coup mon frère il est parti
pour voir ce qu'il y avait voilà
et du coup mon frère quand il est parti
devant
devant le lycée
il était sous un bras c'est pas normal
en fait à 8h du matin
mon frère il est là en cours à l'école
[Musique]
mon frère il allait en cours à l'école à
8h du matin et voilà
on arrive il y a voilà
c'est quand même quelque chose de grave
quand même bien sûr c'est très grave
c'est doux c'est pas normal de nos jours
ça arrive de plus en plus c'est trop
grave qu'est-ce qui c'est d'où vous
l'avez c'est quand elle parle de votre
grand frère c'est vous qui avez
comment vous avez appris à Noël aussi
comment moi c'est un ami à moi qui qui
m'a appelé j'étais au travail
et du coup dès qu'on m'a dit c'est
Tidiane Tidiane il a été poignardé
poignarder niveau du cou quoi c'est une
exécution c'est un meurtre
franchement c'est un assassinat et ça a
été prémédité et c'est ça qui est grave
alors vous avez nous raconter tout ça
parce que tout ce que vous avez pu
entendre
c'est pas du tout la bonne version et
voilà il y a pas de problème de
réglement de compte etc ça n'a rien à
voir vous allez voir le profil de
Tidiane dans un instant si vous allez
nous en parler et ça n'a rien à voir
agile avant
qu'on reparle avec séduit là parce qu'on
va les laisser un peu voilà
un peu tranquille l'histoire
incroyable et c'est vrai que voilà ce
garçon il est pas de problème et on dit
même selon les témoignages qui ont été
recueillis devant l'établissement
scolaire
il se serait même interposé c'est à dire
que il aurait même voulu faire calmer
les les belligérants les esprits c'est
ça qui est le plus incroyable c'est à
dire que on dit parfois victimino centre
ça veut pas dire grand-chose mais là
c'est vraiment lui il a voulu calmer et
puis il est il est tombé devant des des
histoires voilà entre voilà ville
voisine alors voilà c'est un adolescent
il est en quelque sorte
qui avait jamais eu de problème avant
aucun problème aucun problème
un bon garçon il allait au foot à la
maison faire des courses ou chez moi
c'est vraiment veillé parce que on sait
que c'est
ces histoires existent depuis bien avant
nous-même bien sûr vous avez vous êtes
combien de frères et sœurs dans la
famille
[Musique]
alors ils seront des comme vous l'avez
dit au lycée comme tous les maths comme
tous les matins il y allait avec des
potes il y a des tout seul comment il
était parti avec un ami comme Noël et
voilà
[Musique]
il est parti normalement ce matin vous
sentiez pas qu'il y avait normalement il
y avait pas de problème Tidiane il
faisait pas partie de des histoires de
bagarre au contraire c'était celui qui
parlait avec ses amis qui disait ça sert
à rien c'est pas intéressant au grandir
avec lui non
samedi j'étais avec lui
sentaient pas qu'il y avait serein
joyeuse sourire on rigolait ensemble
il n'était pas dedans
donc pour lui il était pas concerné donc
je pense qu'il avait pas forcément peur
parce que lui pour lui il faisait pas
partie de voilà il était pas dedans
voilà c'était quelqu'un qui allait à
l'école un enfant studieux clairement
voilà il est respectueux serviable quand
on lui demande un truc sans problème
sans problème sans problème
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors devant
le lycée parce qu'il y a eu plein de
voilà de théories voilà il y a plein de
gens qui ont avancé théories très
distinctes et on a parlé de un moment de
de bon de rivale confie entre bon rivale
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé réellement ce
matin là alors clairement
[Musique]
à 8h et ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'en
fait les enfants de enfin les garçons
choisit le roi ils ont fait des barrages
dans les rues au niveau du lycée ils ont
fait des barrages et en fait
et en fait dès qu'il y avait un enfant
qui passait il leur demandait bah toi tu
habites où toi tu habites où toi tu
habites où et en gros si tu habites à
Thiais dans un quartier bien précis
enfin à côté de chez nous voilà et ben
voilà
donc ils ont fait des barrages
tranquillement dans la ville personne
n'a vu ça personne n'a alerté personne
n'a alerté les autorités par l'instant
donc ils arrêtaient donc les les jeunes
qui allaient à l'école c'est ça qui est
grave en fait ce genre de choses ça
c'est souvent arrivé les années
précédentes en fait donc il y a déjà eu
quoi ce genre de conflits en fait
beaucoup de conflits entre deux villes
donc voisine entre Thiers choisis
choisis le roi c'est ça oui entretien
choisit le roi il y avait toujours une
guerre ça ça a démarré depuis bien avant
que que moi je sois au collège ou autre
ça date ça remonte à des générations des
générations aussi à l'époque
les enfants ils jouent pas avec des
couteaux ma génération il ne jouait pas
avec des couteaux au pire il se taper
dessus et puis fin ça c'est réglé mais
il jouait pas avec des couteaux
donc là il y avait ces jeunes donc il
faisait barrage ça s'est raconté ce qui
s'est passé réellement donc il demandait
donc à tous les jeunes de passer de quel
où ils habitaient voilà et s'ils étaient
de Thiais d'un endroit précis qu'est-ce
qui se passait et bah à ce moment-là bah
quand mon frère il l'a dit là où il
habitait après il savait déjà d'avance
là où il habitait parce que c'est des
villes à côté tout le monde se connaît
il y a un des il y a une des personnes
en fait qui faisait qui était dans sa
classe très clairement c'est quelqu'un
de sa classe il y a une personne de sa
classe et il y avait une personne de
Choisy-le-Roi c'est des villes qui sont
collées c'est facile de savoir qui
habite où quoi donc savoir l'emploi du
temps et donc visiblement ils
attendaient
j'attendais des gens de
donc là
votre réalité avec son avec son pote
donc là il y a ces garçons de
choisy-le-grand ils sont ils sont
combien ils sont ils sont cinq c'est ça
alors non c'est pas exactement
moi de ce que j'ai pu parler avec
certains de ses amis on m'a dit qu'il y
avait 10 personnes dans tous les cas
quand bien même que ça soit 5 ou 10
donc là mais comment comment on peut en
arriver à poignarder quelqu'un à mort
devant son lycée juste parce qu'il
habite dans un quartier qui correspond
pas à ce que voulait ces jeunes après je
pense qu'il joue beaucoup c'est
ce qu'on peut attendre aussi dans les
musiques
les rappeurs leurs paroles etc etc les
réseaux sociaux tout ça ça joue et puis
il y a des parents qui baissent les bras
avec leurs enfants mais est-ce que avant
il avait eu des menaces sur les réseaux
sociaux est-ce qu'il y avait pas reçu de
ménage il a rien eu il faisait pas
partie de sa très clairement il a pas
reçu de ménage rien aucun problème c'est
vraiment il allait à l'école et il est
plus rentré clairement c'est ça qui
s'est passé et moi ce que je trouve
grave quand même c'est qu'on est en
France et que c'est quand même quelque
chose de très très grave je sais pas si
certains d'entre vous ont des enfants
mais vous vous rendez compte quand même
8h du matin votre enfant va à l'école il
ne reviendra plus non mais si
pour l'instant voilà mais aujourd'hui
donc
votre frère n'est jamais revenu à la
maison vous avez vu son pote
ce qui lui est arrivé je sais juste
qu'il a été planté à la cuisse on a vu
son frère hier mais on n'a pas eu on l'a
pas vu on n'a pas eu
plus d'informations est-ce que vous
savez s'il y a eu des mots avant si ça
s'est ça s'est dit quoi parce que
ces jeunes
qui sont arrivés et les ont poignardé
direct parce qu'il y a eu une
altercation en fait c'est très compliqué
de savoir parce que c'est eux-mêmes
quand on leur pose la question pourquoi
vous pourquoi vous êtes en embrouille
ils seront même pas capables de vous
dire pourquoi ils sont en embrouille
parce que l'histoire d'un tarot
tellement à des années je comprends même
pas
pourquoi oui mais c'est eux qui ont
commencé moi c'est ça qu'on m'a répondu
oui mais c'est eux qui ont commencé ils
ont tapé un ami à moi ils ont pris des
vêtements mais ça engendrait tout ça
mais en plus votre frère il avait rien à
voir là dedans il n'avait rien à voir
dedans donc après qui a eu cette
altercation que vous dites il avait tapé
un ami à eux de choisir le roi ils ont
décidé
de d'agresser tous les gens qui venaient
de Thiais c'est jaune ils sont dit voilà
on va on va se faire justice nous-mêmes
et on va agresser et donc ces jeunes ces
jeunes c'est quoi leur profil ils ont
quel âge Gilles alors ils sont jamais
parce que les trois interpellés ont 15
et 16 ans celui qui a été placé en garde
à vue le premier lui et largement connu
des services de police il a deux
procédures une devant un juge des
enfants une avec un juge d'instruction
pourquoi il était connu profil de
délinquant violence aggravée
participation à un attroupement armé en
mai 2021
voilà donc voilà donc ce qui se passe
c'est une fois une fois de plus il a les
jeunes de 1980 et 2000 c'est pas les
jeunes de 2022 donc là une fois de plus
voilà il faut voir il faut revoir tout
ça parce que on peut pas laisser voilà
des gars qui
rentrent en maison d'arrêt qui repartent
c'est pas possible
bientôt être jugé là ça va changer
devant un tribunal pour enfants et
lui-même le plus
délirant je trouve lui-même avait porté
plainte en décembre après une première
rixe donc avec tout son passé judiciaire
il avait lui-même porté plainte après
une première altercation est-ce que vous
disiez cyril est vrai c'est l'expédition
punitive le guet-apens tendu de la bande
de Choisy-le-Roi qui vient se venger
donc on ne sait même pas quoi c'est ça
qui est le plus fou et qui tombe sur
quelqu'un qui n'a rien à voir avec ses
querelles de bande rien à voir du tout
alors vous avez vu le profil des
suspects
pour vous il s'agit d'un meurtre
prémédité c'est un meurtre prémédité
quel enfant va se lever à 8 heures du
matin
et dire bah aujourd'hui je vais aller
planter quelqu'un non c'est ça a été
prémédité que très clairement ça a été
prémédité et ce que je trouve ça enfin
ce qui est grave dans cette histoire
quand même c'est que cette personne là
elle a un casier judiciaire qu'est-ce
qu'elle faisait dehors il y a pas de
contrôle enfin je sais pas au niveau de
la justice ça se passe comment au bout
d'un moment il y a peut-être un oui mais
au bout d'un moment moi j'aimerais bien
en fait que ça s'arrête à mon frère et
qu'on fasse réellement quelque chose
c'est pour ça que vous êtes venus fort
aussi
ce soir c'est doux et Mina parce que
aujourd'hui vous dites c'est vraiment
c'est fou de dire que c'est un meurtre
prémédité parce que
ça veut dire que pour vous le c'est ces
trois ados sont partis le matin ils sont
dit on va aller vraiment commettre un
meurtre et pourtant la veille il y avait
des des grandes notre de notre quartier
qui sont allés notamment dans les cités
là-bas pour essayer de calmer les
tensions etc
ça a rien fait
le lundi mon frère il est mort
pour ceux qui viennent les connaissaient
ou pas du tout
je pense qu'ils connaissaient je pense
que
de temps sa classe donc forcément il le
connaît
oui il y en avait un qui était dans sa
classe
donc après forcément oui il en
connaissait un après peut-être de vue
voilà ils ont dû peut-être se voir parce
que
ils ont voulu aussi et voulait
s'attaquer à Tidiane particulièrement
aussi bah je pense que oui parce que
elle est visée le coup de mon frère du
coup il faut c'est que vraiment il
voulait le porter ça parce qu'il faut le
rappeler
oui ils se sont déplacés armés couteau
de gazeuses qu'on a retrouvé des clubs
de golf pour frapper des morceaux de
bois qui pourraient s'apparenter aussi
peut-être à des morceaux de batte de
baseball enfin voilà donc ils sont venus
en expédition Unity armée
pour frapper et donc sans doute pour
tuer absolument c'est ça qui est
terrifiant dans cette histoire c'est ça
qui est absolument terrifiant c'est
cette violence de jeunes de 15-16 ans
contre d'autres qui est épouvantable et
épouvantable aujourd'hui qui
vous aimeriez qu'il arrive assez assez
jeune qui sont suspectés si il s'avère
que ce sont bien moi j'aime dire que
passer un certain âge l'âge de 16 ans il
savait ce qu'il faisait
exactement on veut que ça change
clairement il faut qu'il soit jugé
aujourd'hui c'est pas 18 ans dans ces
cas-là voilà il était pleinement
conscient de ce qu'il faisait
à 8h c'est que tu sais ce que tu fais
quand même ta tête tu as dormi il s'est
réveillé allez hop donc d'un moment faut
voilà nous on aimerait qu'il y ait une
sanction qui soit prise déjà par rapport
à ça et franchement qui prennent en fait
plein pot très clairement parce qu'en
fait il y a un moment donné
qu'est-ce qui je sais pas ce qui risque
mais vraiment la totale aujourd'hui
s'il était reconnu coupable il risque
comme il est mineur il peut aller la
peine maximale divisé par 2 donc ce
serait la perpétuité divisée par deux je
pense qu'il peut risquer 20 ans de
prison
risquer 20 ans de prison s'il est
condamné pour cette affaire on vous
dites le max le maximum qui est possible
qu'on pourrait faire et qui soit jugé
comme un adulte c'est pas la première
fois que c'est pas la première fois
c'est un récidiviste il y a rien qui a
été acté enfin il y a rien qui a été
fait contre ça donc il y a au bout d'un
moment faudrait bien que ça s'arrête et
pour que ça s'arrête en fait faudrait
prendre des vraies décisions sérieuses
que l'État vraiment mette en place
quelque chose parce que ça peut plus
continuer Tidiane c'est c'est pas le
premier
c'est pas le premier ça sera peut-être
pas le dernier mais on aimerait bien
vraiment que ça parce que ça s'arrête là
c'est pas normal on est en France quand
même
aujourd'hui dans quel état sont vos
parents
ils ont quoi ils en ont rien
à l'intérieur ils sont limites ils sont
plus là ils sont plus là quand on est
parti de tout le monde qui est mort
quand on est le grand frère et la grande
sœur est-ce qu'à un moment on a des des
idées noires qui nous qui nous
traversent l'esprit on se dit on va se
faire juste ici soi-même
le jour même le jour même plus
la colère elle prend vraiment peut-être
le dessus mais
faut on prend le temps de réfléchir vu
qu'on est tous ensemble on prend le
temps de réfléchir après on prend soin
des autres
c'est important c'est ça qui et puis
même ce qui est important que j'aimerais
dire c'est que
suite à la mort de Tidiane il n'y a pas
eu des meute donc c'est quand même le
fait de ce que
il représentait quoi
c'est à dire que de la paix et pas dans
une il était pas dans une bande dessinée
en fait c'est que ça a pas bougé
derrière ça a rien bouger et pourquoi
j'arrive pas à comprendre
qu'est-ce que le mec était dans sa
classe en plus
il était au courant depuis vendredi
qu'il y avait des problèmes avec
certains enfants font voilà et ils ont
rien fait il y a pas de prévention qui a
été fait au niveau des parents enfin
quelque chose comme ça normalement vous
appelez les parents au moins prévenir
dire oui voilà en ce moment c'est un peu
tendu
il savait par exemple quotidienne ou
d'autres élèves étaient en danger ou pas
du tout bah je pense que je pense que un
certain qu'il savait forcément on sait
pas que les autres les autres élèves à
ce qu'il savait qu'il y avait les gilles
alors le vendredi c'est vrai qu'il y a
déjà eu des événements de de prémices de
rivalité entre les bandes des deux
villes avec des interpellations c'est là
où on peut se dire quand même que
si le vendredi il y a une sorte de
d'expédition de violence qui tourne au
cours parce qu'il y a des
interpellations
je préjugue de rien mais est-ce qu'il
aurait pas fallu sécuriser les abords
des établissements scolaires sachant
qu'il y avait eu des rixes entre banque
déjà le vendredi et là on est quelques
jours après il y a un poste de police
municipale juste à côté du lycée donc je
comprends pas vraiment je comprends pas
pourquoi c'est passé
par rapport
aux gens qui surveillaient les autres
qui les empêchaient donc là on se dit
que il y a quand même des carences en
matière de prévention et de répression
qui sont incroyables et qui a
aboutissent un drame Bernard il y a déjà
eu des antécédents malheureux il y a eu
le 9 janvier un jeune homme de 18 ans
qui a été poignardé à
Champigny-sur-Marne le 13 janvier un
lycée un qui a reçu 10 coups de couteau
déjà entre Saint-Maurice et
Maisons-Alfort vous voyez on pouvait
déjà s'inquiéter de la situation qu'ils
ont venimeux c'est parce que ces risques
sérix au quartier ça a toujours existé
en fait ça a toujours été
malheureusement et souvent vous l'avez
dit très justement mademoiselle on ne
sait pas pourquoi c'est soit des
conneries ces questions de réputation
entre quartiers vous savez l'enjeu on le
connaît pas en réalité ça peut être les
réseaux sociaux ou autre et en tout cas
il y a une chose qui a dit de ce matin
Éric Ciotti il a dit je veux je voudrais
supprimer l'excuse de minorité ça c'est
important ici ce serait nouveau et ça ce
serait efficace c'est-à-dire que
l'excuse qu'on dit vous savez quand on
ignore les peines parce que ce sont des
mineurs bien sûr mais celle-là on dit
depuis
ce que veulent midnight pour vous c'est
pour vous pour vous ils ont toutes leurs
têtes pour vous ce sont des des hommes
et pareil après je suis désolé mais les
parents aussi ils ont quelque chose à
avoir il y a un moment donné ton fils il
va pas à l'école il est 8h du matin
voilà est-ce que ils peuvent le savoir
je pense que ton enfant il rentre tu
sais enfin oh non
qu'est-ce que vous avez eu des des
soutiens de de politique de du maire de
la ville déjà qu'est-ce qui vous ont dit
ils vous ont dit quoi lui on a eu des
soutiens du et vous dites quoi c'est
quoi
qui vous dit quoi qu'il allait voir pour
qu'on puisse mettre des actions en place
au niveau de la prévention des lycées
mais en fait c'est beaucoup plus profond
c'est ça que c'est pas ça qui va régler
le problème en fait ce qu'il faudrait
c'est sécuriser réellement les écoles ça
tardait vraiment sur ça parce que c'est
c'est important moi c'est pas normal
qu'un enfant part à l'école à 8h et se
fasse poignarder en fait on est où là
très clairement donc en fait faudrait
faudrait vraiment mettre des actions en
place commencer à se concentrer parce
que clairement ça fait un moment c'est
pas c'est Tidiane c'est pas le premier
ça sera sûrement pas voilà ça sera
sûrement peut-être pas le dernier
j'espère vraiment très sincèrement du
fond de mon cœur que ça va s'arrêter à
mon frère mais il faudrait vraiment
faire quelque chose
en plus tignane n'avait rien à voir
c'est un garçon comme vous dites qui
travaillait très bien qui était studieux
qui s'occupait pas de tout ça et qui
s'est retrouvé aujourd'hui voilà dans un
dans une rixe et qui est attaqué par
pour une connerie par des des
bombes rivales c'est aujourd'hui
c'est domina vous avez parlé des parents
vous avez parlé de la justice et parler
bien sûr des
suspects ils ont voulu j'en voulais à
qui vous aimeriez qu'il se passe quoi
maintenant moi franchement j'en veux à
l'établissement pour pas avoir su
protéger mon frère j'en veux
à l'état aussi parce qu'il faudrait
peut-être mettre quelque chose en place
Tidiane c'est pas c'est pas le premier
on aurait pu éviter ça s'il y aurait eu
des actions qui auraient été faites je
sais ce qu'ils vont oui ils m'ont dit on
peut pas mettre un policier derrière
tous les élèves oui mais au moins
sécurisé enfin je sais pas il y a des
oui mais en fait il y a des la
prévention à faire dans les écoles dans
les classes ça prend en quoi il y avait
plus de moyens en éducation aussi pour
peut-être mettre des les gars qui sont
juste là pour surveiller parce que la
police aujourd'hui sont sous-effectifs
et forcément ils peuvent voilà et c'est
ce qu'ils vont vous dire aussi vous
pouvez pas c'est je vous dis c'est des
drames qui on se disent tout ce que
c'est des drames qui peuvent être
évitées
si on est venu ici c'est juste pour
rendre hommage à tidjan parce que c'est
vraiment ce qui lui est arrivé c'est
[Musique]
c'est c'est trop c'est trop triste c'est
trop triste là pour vous c'est c'est
vraiment un drame et aux parents à place
de Mina ce qu'on veut vraiment c'est
vraiment que ça cesse il y en a assez en
fait c'est
trop on aimerait vraiment on va vont
souffrir encore et
une sanction exemplaire surtout
pour que j'espère vraiment que ça se
reproduise plus et j'aimerais vraiment
une sanction exemplaire en tout cas si
il y a des politiques ou quelqu'un qui
qui
aimerait une sanction qui qui montre que
voilà on est en France on est dans un
pays on est protégé et que c'est la
France et que c'est la République c'est
vraiment ça qu'on veut voir aujourd'hui
on veut vraiment qu'une action soit mise
en place pour que ça se reproduise pas
moi je franchement de tout cœur je veux
vraiment que ça s'arrête à mon frère et
que ça ne se refasse plus qu'on est plus
de gens qui viennent sur des plateaux
pour dire voilà mon fils il est mort
parce qu'il est parti à l'école